as as a teenager you're so kind of like
uh pressured even if it's not like even
if it's just like maybe a fake pressure
or maybe like a fake expectation just to
like find a girl and like lose your
virginity as fast as [__] possible
right I mean that's that's the thing
though that's the thing at least when I
was a [__] teenager you know I think
it was like the American Pie yeah the
[__] American Pie you know it's like
you got you're going to prom you're
going to prom and you're not losing your
virginity what the [__] especially at a
[__] boys school Jesus Christ this is
everything like after school so all
right boys we're gonna go get some
[__] [__] yeah so I'm just like bro
just don't I know just stop don't invite
me and now I just look back at that
moment of time and I'm like I just
cringe because I was like yeah okay yeah
I'm a horny teenage boy reaching
Community you know yeah I think losing
my beauty is one of the shittiest
experiences
it was one of the just the worst yeah
everything I was like awful yeah it was
just a bad time I was like this nothing
inherently bad about it it was just the
most underwhelming everything was [__]
yeah I was [__] yeah they were [__]
everything was [__] uh yeah it was just
all around terrible terrible time I
don't think anyone I don't think anyone
walked away from the situation happy all
right yeah it's I I've heard like a lot
of losing your virginity stories
including mine and every everyone's had
like the same reaction of just like that
was it basketball everyone [__] hyped
up really really no I thought it was
pretty high oh [__] of course Joey of
course God God damn it well I mean I I
lost my virginity like I guess I don't
know when is the period that is like the
most suitable to lose your virginity
because you know there are a lot of
instances I lost my virginity late or I
lost my virginity early like what is
what is that time trick question there
is no suit yeah that right it's when it
just [__] happens exactly and when
the Lord deems it
I was like Jesus is taking all the time
okay thank you I don't think there's a
correct time I think whatever you feel
comfortable with because I'm sure
there's a lot of people out there who
may be rushed into it yeah and probably
had a horrible experience and probably
regretted it yeah I see my experience
wasn't terrible like my experience
wasn't like [__] traumatizing it was
just yeah it was just like that was a
bit of [__] wasn't it yeah like it was
that kind of hard it was like it wasn't
like and it was and it was purely
because I was just like go go let's find
out what I've got to get at it if you
don't mind if you don't mind sharing how
old were you uh I I was I was 17 17.
yeah yeah
18. it's okay I'm the oldest but I I was
22 but I had actually I think it's I
think the considering the fact that you
had like the most positive experience
out of us yeah uh probably like just
don't be in high school when you lose
your virginity be an adult I'd had other
experiences before that yeah um and that
was definitely like oh well this is
weird
because I didn't know the [__] I was
doing yeah I'm a [__] kid yeah yeah
um yeah I mean I I will say probably
it's not all media and social pressure
uh you know there is a point when you're
a teenager where hormones definitely
creep up you know and yeah absolutely
and you're like holy [__] what is
what the [__] is what's going on I need
to fix this immediately oh God oh God oh
God see you guys you guys were like you
guys were like you know there at the
right time and you knew the solution
it's like okay I know exactly how to do
this just you know get laid Yeah so I
had that exact same idea it's just like
I had negative reasons yeah so I
couldn't get it as much as I want to say
boys we live in a society
it's not always okay okay that's true oh
sorry I the having negative risk does
not [__] matter there are there are
people who you are probably uh sexually
attracted to is like a teenager when
you're both teenage obviously yeah you
know when you're both teenagers they
also probably had negative written you
know yeah it's not only the good looking
people who are getting [__] done you
know what I mean like I have negative
rich and I I you know we would I'd date
other people with negative wrists and it
was just [__] awkward
we would just have a time you know maybe
that's it maybe maybe I knew that I was
like oh if I date someone with negative
risk well I also have negative risk then
it's just not even gonna be good I'm so
glad I I [__] everything up when I was
a teenager because I was like I didn't
know what this was and like one time
dude just like learning [__] because
you're just a [__] idiot kid yeah
that's inside classified and we were
talking and uh I don't know how this
conversation came about because they
were like something something Simon and
I was like yeah how many girls have that
right
what
right they were like do you assuming
this I was like I'll be wrong no I don't
and they just mocked me relentlessly
yeah but I'm like man I'm a [__]
idiot no one told me what the [__] was
like I got my whole [__] adult life a
Teenage life not learning what the [__]
was because I come from a [__] small
ass town and I wasn't researching this
by the way ladies I'm single like I
would look online but I I would I was
not the kind of dude who would like I
like dude there was I I don't know if
it's just like a weird thing and I feel
like maybe maybe kids get into this way
earlier like when I was like 15 I was
not Googling [__] about like sexual
stuff at all no I was too focused on
games
way too focused on these priorities so I
didn't even like I didn't even give a
[__] about porn or anything like that
until I was like 17. yeah I just didn't
give a [__] because this is not what I
was interested in so when I was trying
to learn all this [__] I was going in
blind I was like oh my God what is
happening I am I have no idea what it's
just like what is that what I just
remember like watching porn and I was
like what the [__] is going on what the
hell is this I remember like trying to
jack off for the first time I was like I
have no idea if I'm doing this right yes
I think this just feels all right do you
remember your first time jacking off
yeah
I do I remember distinctly I don't know
why I have this memory I was playing
Halo Reach I feel like I've had this
conversation no we have not had this
conversation this is when Halo Reach
came out and I remember the exact map I
was playing on before I jacked up
all right
it's time I remember the setup I I just
remember that like I was playing Halo
Reach which means I must have been when
did Halo Reach come out can we get a
yeah we're getting we're gonna go you
can get an exact age when I discovered
jacking off yeah it was it was late I
didn't start jacking off till later yeah
2010 so I was I was 14 so probably it
came out I'll probably like 14. yeah
that sounds about right I was about that
age yeah and I just remember being like
when I when I was you know because you
you heard how do you learn to jack off
your friends just always talk about it
right no dude I hurt myself the first
time I did it yeah what the [__] you're
doing yeah and the only way I'd learned
is because I heard about it from my
other friends who were like oh yo jack
off I'm like yeah me too and I was like
what the [__] is that I was doing it
like I was starting a fire I was like
because I was like I know you have to do
something but I was just like I'll just
[__] do this
I was like this hurts I'm gonna go Bear
Grylls yeah
don't do that that [__] hurts
oh my God yeah okay I just remember this
is the first time I tried to do it I was
like God damn this [__] is just [__]
pain yeah yeah like am I doing it I must
be doing this song yeah like because you
obviously you get taught so much [__]
about like you can talk about like sperm
and stuff yeah and they wouldn't they
wouldn't tell us anything about what it
was and I used to just think that like
random [__] was sperm I'd be like this
this thing on my dick this must be spoke
and I'm like what the [__] no this is
not Schwab this is not sperm at all and
then everything the first time I I
managed to this is so over over detail I
feel something I managed to like [__]
jack off successfully mission
accomplished I remember being like oh
what the [__] is this [__] oh get the
[__] out of here what the hell this is
nasty and I didn't know that was gonna
happen
you don't learn about having tissues
oh my God what the [__]
stop please
unprepared for it yeah I don't know I
don't like did you have like a stage
because like how I like uh how I like I
guess learned because uh I guess uh I I
remember like get it my first time like
get it you know getting getting an
erection right yeah I don't remember the
first time do you remember no not at all
I feel I think I just got because you
know you just you just gets hard right
yeah yeah like your dick just gets hard
randomly and like and like it would be
like a nuisance for me because I I would
not I would not understand why this
happened she was just seeing brother and
sister yeah
he's a pretty little things to come yeah
so so like remember the first time I got
one I was just like uh what is this uh
what the [__] is this and then like uh
you know I wouldn't do anything because
I didn't know how to jack off back then
so um I would just like wait for it to
go down and yeah for it to pass and I
didn't get why this would happen because
it would be like really inconvenient for
me just to have like a massive [__]
you didn't like say boobs and we're like
oh no no that's what happened
generally sometimes it would just like
you know it's sometimes it just [__]
happens especially especially as a team
the no reason boner uh that that was
just like My Teenage life yeah like this
is uh this is kind of like inconvenient
uh this takes up a lot of space in my
trousers and I don't know why it's
happening uh so I I basically one time I
was just like I'm gonna try and get rid
of this somehow so he was a literal like
it was a literal troll by error first I
started like trying to [__] smack it
[__] smack it away it's like stop yes
and then they'll and then like well and
then like buy trial and error
um I just realized wait why does why
does this feel sensitive I don't get it
and then it just and then it's just like
oh is this that jacking off people
talking about
smack the [__] out of here
I I I'm just like that was that was a
cool memory that I just completely
forgot oh my god oh so we've had Bear
Grylls we've had [__] smacking it
yeah I'm just genuinely curious now how
people how people find this [__] out I
don't even remember how I figured out
like oh that that is not the right way
to do it I'm like I think I can't
remember I think there's just so much
information out there yeah well you
don't need to worry about having to
figure this [__] out yeah because you
could be told how to do it oh I think I
I think I remember why I I remember at
the correct way to do it because I was
like my friend was like showing me this
Pawn on his phone and like you know back
then another thing that teenagers do
that's weird yeah yeah on the [__]
school bus on the way to school and you
know like it was the flip phone so I was
like [__] 2 40 p.m you can barely see
[__] anything on this tiny screen
he's like check this [__] porn video
out it's pretty sick and I was watching
it and I remember specifically it was
like Johnny Sins or someone I don't
remember but there was the male guy and
he was like J owing and I'm like that's
how you do it oh
no wonder they [__] hard that's not how
now I know how to do it I just can't
fathom the world where you thought you
had to do that I I don't know I was just
like this makes this just this makes the
most sense this is why you had no
[__] yeah this is why I had negative
rims because I was [__] jailing doing
this oh my God oh my God you just you
just [__] unlocked a core memory yeah
you you uh because I I completely forgot
about this but like even
um I think this was like before I
learned how to jack off yeah right like
so I think I discovered porn before I
discovered how to jack off and I didn't
make the correlation yeah yeah I think
me too yeah yeah
uh because I I remember like uh we uh I
had a sleepover one time with my mates
right and normally on most sleepovers
um normally on my sleepovers we just
play [__] N64 and just uh play uh
Super Smash Brothers uh until like the
[__] son comes up or whatever not
that kind of season
um and then one time um
my mate was like oh can we uh can I use
your PC and uh he starts downloading
porn on LimeWire and I had no idea what
the [__] he was downloading and he
downloaded this like [__] like yeah
you know obviously we're on dial up at
the time so we downloaded he downloaded
this like one like one minute clip which
you know too still took a while yeah and
he shows it to me and I got like my
mom's just having this realization of
this one sleepover that we're having as
a kid and he shows it to me and it's
like the most [__] amazing thing I've
ever seen in my life there are three of
us and we will just stand we were just
all sitting back dude look at it like
monkeys we're just like gorping and I
was just like I turned on me and I'm
like is that like a full version of this
and so the entire night we are uh we we
find the full version of whatever clip
that he's uh he's found it's like a 20
minute clip takes all night to download
yeah uh we stay up all night this is the
most mid-2000s it is it is it is uh play
a place of video games didn't get any
sleep that night
um and at around I think like 5 00 a.m
we could start to see the sun rise out
we're like oh boys it's happening it's
finished and and the last thing we do on
the sleepover and like my mum and dad
are asleep like upstairs and stuff we're
just all like huddled around we're all
huddled around in silence just watching
like watching this porno and it's like
it's the most amazing thing I've ever
seen in my life I'm like
[Music]
what is this what
boys can do that
I don't understand
and uh is this what races yeah and uh
that guy ruined me for my uh for my life
because I was like well now I know uh
now I'm only downloading one thing on
LimeWire and it ain't music anymore
oh God did you have any um
uh pregnancies in your school
uh no because I went to a boys school
that would have been
that would have been a difference
privileged no but like uh because we I
went to the boys school and then down
the road there was like the sister
school which was the whole girl school
and yeah there were some stories of like
people getting pregnant in the sister
school I don't know we
um had quite a big push on like sex
education yeah we had that too because I
think the area I grew up in was like the
I had like the highest rate of teen
pregnancy in the UK oh damn uh of course
there's nothing to do oh yeah yeah
um so yeah I remember there was like I
think you have one or two in my year I
think but I remember the other they just
randomly I think started really pushing
it being like hey guys use condoms I'm
like bro I don't even know how to jack
off how do you think I'm gonna figure
this [__] out what are you I I don't
know I'm gonna play Halo Reach I'm not
I'm not worried about this I'm trying to
get those next Point Sports yeah I felt
like we had the we had these lashes it
was like catered towards a very specific
group in our schools I think I was just
like bro I'm just trying to learn dude
every time like for me that the thing
that annoyed me was like you know during
sex education they were like okay guys
remember if you're going to have sex
which is nothing wrong about because
you're all in puberty make sure to use a
condom and in my head I'm just like
where
how how do you require these things I've
never even seen them out in the world
who has them
from you didn't tell [__]
just like the
when you think about having sex it's
like you've got to go out and buy them
but they never taught me where to get
them so I'm like well thanks for that
information
um I'm gonna do nothing about that I'm
gonna go home and play Mario party
let's turn into games yes yeah nothing
else is happening yeah exactly